good morning guys Greg Alba here
Donald Humphrey Andrew Andrew Gordon's
with us today it's 5:30 in the morning
we are three women who are proud that
Captain Marvel is dropping now are you
guys excited for the trailer people I am
I have been researching all night I have
been researching for the past day let's
see how much I retained Andrew has seen
him in the end not him at one point
research andrew has more information
than all of us that's why he's here and
thank you to the patrons to notify
minute this was up transition we have a
patreon people we do TV show reactions
over their shows like my hero academia
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Gotham supernatural and
Riverdale we also do weekly Q&A s which
are a total blast so please go over and
check out our patreon it's a lot of fun
and please make sure to check out Andrew
Gordon's YouTube channel people he's
constantly here whenever we need him
he's such a good friend of ours please
show him some support by checking out
his channel anyway guys enough talk
enough chitchat it's pretty early for
brie Larson on Good Morning America
right now let's get to this
I am video should crash laughter
blockbuster Wars a universal language
and the renegade soap to pursue never
occurred to me that one might come from
above my shadow water
[Music]
space invasion
garcy
miss you today it's hard to explain
[Music]
keep happy memories
here
[Music]
I can't tell
Oh
[Music]
your blog
yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
mmm cool cool this puts a smile on my
face more to do it one more time
I wonder how accurately that the tone of
this trailer is because in the movie The
Hollywood video there's a real white
kind of a sci-fi alien mystery line over
to us yeah let's pick up on Sam Jackson
saying Wars universe ooh I like this
like rookie level of looking for supers
that Sam Jackson said yeah
the catamites Evangelina Hubert doesn't
look like the aging
[Music]
these memories
[Music]
I feel like this is gonna be a really
unique origin tale because because it's
clearly hopping around different time
[Music]
it's just starting to film all already
with ours but then she's gonna be having
these flashbacks that I'd like more than
just flashbacks looks like a really
gonna spend time it does this
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah especially if she's supposed to be
like the most powerful hero we're gonna
see them see I don't think we did more
not really yeah no obviously it goes
without saying that Marvel's visuals are
awesome and I'm very excited for this
film the plot I'm very much intrigued by
when we did the Captain Marvel first
look reaction over the pictures I kind
of made it was making fun of her face
yeah her face it kinda had this blank
stare her like every one of them but
that's usually first photos for any of
these films you know oh yeah but then
watching this trailer she tells her she
doesn't seem that like emotionally
intense in this movie either it kind of
reminds me of those like sci-fi 90s
movies like what's that one with Jeff
Bridges that John Carpenter film star or
star man yes yes star man kind of this
like one I know she's human who gets her
powers by mixing DNA with Kree and there
is kind of this like wandering lost
alien like vibe that she has come food
which I appreciate I like it but there
is something about her performance it
seems incredibly subtle who do you know
to the point where I'm like where's the
emotional intensity but I imagine it'll
probably play better in the context of
the film well yeah what I'm hoping that
maybe a second trailer will do more to
flesh out these smaller elements of the
movie or the more there's the little
bits of personality from all the
characters and some because this seemed
like you wanted to communicate the
overall tone and scope of the movie it
almost felt like it was you know down to
earth but also very encompassing of some
of the broader more cosmic elements that
they brought in lately yeah with all
these like really symmetrical shots and
very bolded it seems like this was
basically their first kind of
establishment of tone and I hope what
they show us next time is more of the
personality and you also mentioned you
know sci-fi like Star Trek II type of
yeah vibe and I felt that too but
they've also Kevin Feige and the
directors of the film have mentioned
that the tone that they're going for
this film is Terminator 2 Judgment Day
and Top Gun so ok interesting from that
point of view you know I mean I didn't
obviously from this trailer field act
but yeah you know when we get into the
context of the film you know if that's
really what they're going for then she
does seem to be embodying the t800
person
well I can see that why did to do
something like that work for this
trailer there we go like okay here's the
stuff that's kind of all our basic
marvelous stuff next time we'll show you
that t2 top gun well I mean if you're
saying top gun especially it's like
usually these first Marvel trailers are
usually very serious yeah I noticed it
tends to be their trend is that they're
they're teasers especially even like
Iron Man 3 which is a very comedic
family yes oh yeah yeah they have a very
heavy trailer this is gonna be an
intense battle yeah but then the the
actual movie has a lot more humor and
stuff Sam Jackson's one of your main
leads you know you're gonna have to mark
Greg back to is Coulson and stuff I'm
very excited 20 is Sam Jackson's the
aging doesn't look like the aging but
quarter correct I've been watching agent
I've been watching agents of shield now
so it's just it's great to actually see
him back in the MCU in terms of the film
so I'm so happy to have him back in you
know just I mean from what we have from
what I've been hearing is Phil Coulson
this is gonna be his first year in she's
so he's a rookie so obviously you know
it's gonna be cool Sam and I remember
there was that line in Iron Man 2 where
you said to Tony Stark this isn't my
first rodeo mr. stark was this the first
rodeo so obviously with Samuel Jackson
or rather with Nick Fury we see he's got
two eyes we know one of those eyes the
right eye is coming out at you know the
question is who's responsible you know
because he said to Captain America and
when her soldier the last time I trusted
someone I lost an eye
could that be Ben Mendelsohn's character
Talos who was playing his boss Oh ed
shield you know and obviously Scrolls
they can shape-shift although his
character Talos could not shape-shift in
the comics so they've clearly changed
that in this that could be the person
that he trusts and you know how he lose
his design so that's the origin I want
that's the main origins I bought and
Ronan you mentioned that he wasn't in
this tree I think it was smart not to
put him in this order
yeah yeah I think it was smart omim this
trailer because I mean we're already
getting like origins of Sam Jackson who
or just Cordray you know you don't want
to overlook yeah you don't want to
overload it and then get distract from
the main focus which is the introduction
the official introduction of Captain
Marvel and this is such a big moment but
I think that is important yeah lead your
first trailer off mostly focused on her
in the tone and I agree because one of
the main complaints about guardians of
the galaxy in terms of the villains were
that Ronan you know there wasn't as much
of a backstory you didn't get a whole
ton on him so I'm glad they are saving
that because I hope they do flesh that
out a little bit in this film because
we'll get more context so people you
know don't as much hate that you know
the character as much when they re watch
guardians the cops'll have a lot more
context you know when they watch this
film so but I agree with you guys it was
a good idea not to show too much of that
I know this takes place in the 90s but
then also you know the the way infinity
war ends it ends with the beeper so I'm
wondering if did the ending of this will
be you know her giving him a beeper yeah
that makes sense because beepers were
huge yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see like where she's been all this time
like what happened like you know if
anything have you to do with the quantum
realm or the time vortex who knows yeah
we'll see it's gonna be interesting how
they all tied together we do got a
mention though we did see a real Ambo
really quickly it was a quick shot the
Maria Rambo and also John mentioned that
he saw a photon oh yeah yeah yeah on the
jet photon that basically they're
setting up her daughter Monica Rambeau
who also known in the comics a spectrum
she's very powerful basically she can
form into any form of energy or she can
transform into any form of energy within
the electromagnetic spectrum huh she's
obviously she's called spectrum so um
but they're setting her up for phase
four and five she's gonna be a big part
of them see you but I like how they're
already saying that up and one thing it
was sad about we didn't get to see brie
Larson's cat or rather Carol Danvers cat
yes really yeah because in the
commentary cat's name is chewy she's a
die-hard Star Wars fan but they're not
naming the catuai and this because they
don't want to do you know get from
merchandising problems with you Funko
hand cuz Disney Lucas you're gonna say
we didn't get to see brie Larson's ass
well justin is to make the cooing Zeus
right yeah
if Joel Schumacher was directing this
film we would definitely get to actually
either shy dutch form saturday yes Thank
You Batman from DOM and the suit would
have nipples
you guys are degrading this is exactly
why we need a movement right anyway guys
the Captain Marvel trailer satisfy you
guys that you guys love what are you
most looking forward to about this film
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
check us out on patreon we got
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is a whole bunch of goodies love to have
you become a patron oject today and also
please subscribe to Andrew Gordon's
YouTube channel it's well worth it he's
been a longtime supporter and the most
reliable buddy to come on the channel
seriously Thank You Man